we flew him all the way from nashville
tennessee he is the number four
lightweight in the world this dude has
more fight options than a youtuber right
now he is the
ufc cash cal come on he's a ufc cash cow
he has one big old fight coming up it's
michael chandler god damn it dude
michael bro if you're gonna do it you
gotta do it right dude i'm a
professional get get your together it's
michael chandler on this week's food
truck diaries and i'm feeding them
kelly's sweet barbecue because we're
both carnivore let's go
it's gotta be close to my mouth i know i
know the direction of this of the sound
you
don't want
[Music]
this is in your first rodeo man you've
been on her a few times recurring guests
man you are man
maybe the most you're up there dude
trying to set records yeah you're
setting records man you're like me on
ridiculousness
they can't get rid of me yeah it's a
cool record to have
uh i think it's fair to say you are the
golden goose of the ufc right now man i
don't know i don't know about that i do
but i mean there's connor who's their
green
golden goose yeah but as far as like
i i think you've become kind of this
undeniable
fighter where your next fight we're
talking
big boy fights and dana and ufc seem to
be on board so to me i'm like oh
mike's about to get paid
we can only hope that's that's the goal
but yeah i mean no i just honestly all
i'm doing is coming in
and when i sat down in the room with
hunter campbell and had that phone call
with dana white it was almost two years
ago at this point i said i want to be a
good thing for your organization i want
to come in and do exactly what i said i
was going to do which was come in
either prove i am who i am right away or
sink or swim and then i could have came
in went 0-2 and got cut but
here we are and uh dude i'm having a
blast here we are you're coming off a
freaking
spartan kick ko one of the might be the
best kale of the year it's uh
it's in the front runner right now you
know it's tony ferguson yeah so who's
never been ko'd before he's been tko'd
but never flat i like that so i mean it
was yeah it was good man and the thing
about that fight too it's not like it
was like like tony was
looked good that's the thing it wasn't
like this like watered-down version tony
ferguson i mean granted he has his fight
miles on him yeah it's still tony
ferguson he's tony ferguson he's
extremely tough so you had to be willing
to get settled in for a 15-minute war
that's what i was prepared for and
obviously that first round he tagged me
a couple times he's he's awkwardly long
and moves awkwardly and he's mimicking
yeah he didn't even hit me with the sand
he didn't hit me with any like you know
the crazy tony stuff but just the way
that he moves his mannerisms they're
different than anybody else you're
training
with in the gym so you kind of had to go
in there and make decisions on the fly
and i kind of threw that kick on a wing
and a prayer up the middle and i don't
think i've ever seen you do that no i
don't do it a lot and i i swear i swear
i can't i can't tell if i'm actually if
i do remember thinking let's see if this
works or if i
watch the replay and i think that's what
i was thinking in the moment but because
i knew cause tony had his hands kind of
here and his elbows were out so i knew
there was a lane up the middle and i
wanted to wanted to threaten the
takedown go high go low go uppercut in
the middle obviously i'm a hands-heavy
guy but i was like let's see if this
works and then all of a sudden oh it
works he's on the ground i'm doing
better
and hopefully it's ko now you're the
cash cow for the ufc i really are dude
you talk about it's like
if i'm the ufc this is what i would do
and again i'm just not like
just spewing this out and there's no
kind of uh kind of gravity behind it
like these are narratives and fights
that could very well happen like if i'm
the ufc they've talked about you and
they diaz you're down for una deals
that's a blockbuster fight i'm down for
this down for you and connor there's a
lot of smoke with that dana was like it
makes a lot of sense chandler connor
makes a lot of sense yeah you know and
then there's you know in your division
you'll have a champ right now so you
look at the way that uh lays out there's
some big fights there which you can get
to but if i'm the ufc you know connor
had the mishap with dustin poiret
whereas leg uh got all messed up yeah
he's rehabbing now they say they'll be
back maybe late december early 2023.
it's up to connor where he wants to do
nate goes dude i want one fight i'm
ready to go chandler's ready to go let
he he's like i'm down to do that fight
too i'm the ufc that's what i do
all right connor we don't have much has
left um nate wants to do just one get
out so who's gonna be around it's gonna
be michael chandler so won't we double
down michael chandler won't we have
chandler take out both of them
yeah and then you and i are going yeah
yeah i'm saying it's like you need to
yes then we buy some food trucks and we
have ours
our own channel shopping
but no ideally i mean there's it's it's
a very interesting division and i do
think because people say man you know
you're 36 you came into the ufc a little
bit late and we kind of talked about
that over the years and i'm like i think
i came in at the exact right time khabib
retires poirier
and connor were tied up in their trilogy
thing or their their rematch i that puts
me in line to fight for the title fight
oliveira for the title i lose
fight of the year against justin gaichi
like everything has come together really
well but neil darius was supposed to
fight islam for the number one contender
spot bonille gets hurt now they're
talking about oliveira versus him
possibly for the title but then you have
aloe vera talking about waiting for
connor and i said oliveira wait for
conor i'll keep the division warm me and
islam will fight for the title in
october uh november whenever whenever
they want to do it i mean i'm i'm here
to work i got my workplace on i think
yeah i love that but i think that's
again that's why you're the cash cow for
the ufc because you've had win loser
draw no boring fights it's exciting
fights you're fighting the
top upper echelon guys they're great
fights you're not like this lame prey
guy so they can sell the fight the fan
base the ufc fan base is familiar with
you and then also
you know obviously you fought charles
oliveira pretty recently that first
round man you could say 10 8 like it was
a great round for you but i think in
order to get back to see that rematch
again
to me when you when you like i'll fight
islam i was like that makes a lot of
sense because if that's for an interim
title then charles oliveira has no
choice but to fight you again yeah
because there's no choice no for sure
now now i will say this and you know i
love the [ __ ] i don't know islam from
you know those people sitting over there
islam i think personally would be your
toughest matchup it's not 55 division
islam is good but what islam has is the
wrestling and i think i negate i negate
his wrestling i do think i do think he
before standing with you i do think so
and i think his fundamentals are pretty
good they're decent yeah but he's you
know he's a southpaw not power right no
he's not a power guy and man i just i
have an ability to get in your face and
make guys who are normally
in your face type of guys get on their
back foot outlaw the justin gateshea
fight you make it ugly yeah i make it
ugly but plus you hit like you're
[ __ ] you're probably yeah well and
well that's and that's where
if oliveira wants to wait out that's
fine we'll keep the division going and
and also you look at me versus oliveira
yeah i was a nat's eyelash away from
finishing him in the first round and i
do believe
i do believe that moment got the best of
me i didn't fight my fight that i needed
to i wanted to go out there i wanted to
get in his face right away because at
that point in time we were still saying
that charles oliveira breaks charles
oliveira isn't as tough as we thought he
was yeah
we stand corrected we all do charles
oliveira is tougher than we thought he's
more confident than we thought he's the
champion he's he's the real champion
even though he doesn't currently isn't
it weird in your division like at 55
like because of that weight mishap yep
you know there's no actual bona fide
champions your division is a little bit
tied up in the gates you can get the
nose surgery so he's out for a while you
got connor kind of looming over all you
guys
you know you got uh michael chavin and
khabib who's a big influence going
makchev's next and then so it's like
this n55 so stashed he had daryus there
they got uh
muhammad and uh you know uh sean brady
so you got all this stuff going on a lot
of guys and there's guys like uh faziov
rafael
or faziv just beat rda so you got these
guys in that that six to ten range that
are kind of coming in and surging you've
got conor who's been out and you're so
stuck and you've seen my handling of
conor as well i mean at some point do i
want to fight the guy of course but we
gotta we do have to cut conor a little
bit of slack he broke his leg in half
and everybody's you know calling them
names and everybody's calling them out
and doing all this stuff there's a
reason they're doing it yeah and
everybody wants the fight but also at
the same time let the guy recover let
the guy
the sport of mixed martial arts and
especially the lightweight division is
better when conor mcgregor is part of it
but he needs to come back at the right
time agree not russia and not russia
massive lagos
snapped his leg in half so so you got
him out and then and if you're talking
about charles who wants the big money
fight and he's made no he's minced no
words on it he wants the big money fight
he thinks he deserves it and i'm like
that's cool do that you deserve to him
what's the money fight connor it's got
to be the counter fight now here if
you're connor coming back here's the
thing when's he coming back also the ufc
is a bit of a predicament here because
you know conor has the leg injury and
then you know
nate diaz has one fight left we know
nate's like listen
let's i just let give me one fight and
then i'm out yeah i the ufc i guarantee
is like you ain't leaving till we get
this connor trilogy then you can go
bounce do what you want to do so i think
conor's next fight is going to be nate
diaz they're not going to let nate diaz
go without that treasure they're not
it's just not happening yeah so i think
that is going to be conor's uh
whether it's his next fight but that's
nate's next fight one thing so so they
got to wait on that that's all they're
doing that all they're doing is playing
the long game with nate and dragging out
dragons which is crazy though because i
love this and me and nate diaz are not
we don't even know each other we're not
friends by any means whatsoever but i
can show enough respect to the guys that
deserve it in my mind and you look at a
guy like nade diaz the question is
does he just take his last fight on his
deal because they offered him hamzad or
they offered him a couple other fights
or whatever does he just take it because
i do think when nate diaz says i ain't
fighting conor i don't want to fight
conor
i think nate diaz is a man of his word
exactly even if it's to his own fault if
all of us are like dude what do you
think and go get the counterfeit because
that's a huge payday no he's a man of
principle yeah whether you want to say
he's a gangster that's why ufc i'm like
cool gangster you do your thing but
connor we know how much he has left
well chandler's down to fight for how
much longer and we can invest him and
make him the face of the division so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
line up connor who will fight you i'll
line up nate real quick he can fight
before connor so nate you take out nate
boom close that chapter take his you
know
fan base whatever you get a lot of his
fan face people love you and i can talk
[ __ ] to him you get his fan base lead up
conor gets healthy you take out connor
and then it's like you take out those
two guys and then we come on over to the
[ __ ] belt again yeah it's like well
and that's how massive you'd be dude and
that's the thing it's it's the you know
it's the cognitive dissonance slash the
playing both sides of the fence where
it's like everything in me wants to be
the champion everything is in me wants
to say who do i fight next to get to the
title and but then there's these these
huge fights these massive massive fights
the legacy fights to get you in the hall
of fame they get you the huge platform
they get you the you know the more
lights the more money and that kind of
stuff so playing
trying to see how the division that is
constantly moving the top ufc and it's
the toughest division in the world and
it's the most exciting division in the
world so there's so many different
options but it is a business
so business would be chandler get the
the golden goose fights renee diaz
connor win those you have more fame and
money that you can handle you also have
a family so you just got another baby
right in april so he was born april so
you have a family take care of get that
bag because those guys are going to be
around too long and the chance of the
fight
one of them is impossible you're in the
talks to fight both of them yeah so
you're making all the money in the world
and then you go over and do the thing
because yeah the short side thing be
like i want islam right now all right
you know well because he's still
building two it's not like he's massive
here yeah no for sure he's definitely
still building but he's a bigger than he
is for sure but but he's also people
talk about win streaks and you look at
me i'm two and two in the ufc but i've
had four of the toughest fights in the
ufc that you could have you've got a guy
like him or even benilderush nothing
against benil daryush but we're just a
couple fights away from him fighting
some guys that aren't even on the roster
you know i mean his win streak
you have to look at strength of schedule
when i said i wanted to come in and top
fight the top the top guys right away
you talk about hooker aloe vera geichi
and ferguson these were all big stakes
where i was taking you know of course
there was the upside of beating these
guys but there's also the downside of
you know losing and now sitting at two
and two but also people won't always
remember your wins and losses they
remember how you made them feel in the
performances so what do you do
besides go out there put your foot on
the gas and have a good time and then
you know get in fights of the year get
in knockouts of the year and that's
that's all i've tried to do since the
very beginning which gives you options
as we stand here
like i said you're the golden goose the
ufc not options for me though like you
know if they call me and say hey we want
you to fight for the title fight for the
title hey we're going to take a detour
here what do you think about fighting
diaz or what do you think about waiting
for connor we don't know how long connor
is going to be out we still don't have a
timeline on that so you know
i think i'm the i i would love to fight
conor would love to fight dc he's a
front runner
the thing you have working against is
those guys do kind of call the shots a
little bit but i do think nate and he's
agreed to fight you already yeah i think
if they call nate like all right you got
chandler in september he might say less
let's do it yeah
and then conor's into he's like that
we'll fight that'll happen so they're
into it and the guy were leaving out and
you got into a
verbal altercation at the last ufc
pay-per-view is dustin poiret who i also
love i love both you guys when i saw you
guys uh bickering i'm like oh what's
happening here he two guys he got into a
verbal altercation why i was i actually
don't what happened you're just walking
i was walking by with my wife no less
you know like first of all you want to
cuss at me and yell at me one thing is
is you know whatever
with your parents
i'm with my wife you know and we're also
in public i'm not the kind of guy who
wants to be in a public altercation and
it's all over the media and gilbert
burns a good friend of mine he was the
one who was taking the video and i'm
like dude yeah he's all checking in yeah
he's like exactly like he's now mma
media but no i mean i heard something
and you know you know how the ufc is man
security guards everywhere i had two
security security guards with me hey
like and i was like what is that he's
like no keep walking keep walking i'm
like no no i'm pretty sure he's pointing
at me and he was pointing at me he was
yelling some things
whatever so i wanted to get close to at
least have a conversation like what are
you saying dude you guys have a history
right
i don't
know no we don't have a history but
here's what we here's what we do have we
had immense amount of respect followed
by immense amount of disrespect on
microphones followed by okay i guess we
don't like each other anymore which you
know we came in my last fight in
bellator august of 2020 whatever i'm
fighting benson henderson he's he's a
cornering one of his buddies
shake it up dab it up dude big fan of
you dude love the way you fight you're
good dude outside the octagon savage
inside blah blah blah good dad great day
yeah
so many then
and he was saying that kind of stuff
about me as well in my career then i
come over to the ufc and then obviously
on the microphone hey if they want me to
fight chandler i'd rather just sell hot
sauce i'm like okay
that's completely different than what we
you know and i get it for him he's a guy
who's been in the ufc for what a decade
and a half or whatever
i'm the new guy i'm the new guy so
it's hard because you're playing you're
playing the emotion you're playing the
actual physical fights you're playing
the chess of divisions and who's who i
come in finished dan hooker in two and a
half minutes which he couldn't do in 25
minutes
so doing backflips calling people out
saying his name saying conor's name so i
i guess some feathers yeah i mean also i
don't i don't
i don't hold anything against guys when
they say stuff uh in interviews or on
the mic it's like they're trying to sell
a fight it's all good
where i had like was kind of like
you know i got tenses like that's like
that was straight up animosity from
dustin it's like whoa there's no mics
there's we don't have to sell this thing
we're not even scheduled to fight dude
oh no it was it was like yeah like
spitting
maybe you're just trying to get a fight
maybe he's frustrated because he you
know maybe he has some options too and
yeah he's like i'm just waiting you know
for the big fight well i mean conor's is
his option right you know if conor
wanted to come back and settle the score
with him they're one-on-one now but
that's a couple months away i mean we're
sitting in july at this point it was the
first of july basically so he's got you
know the rest of the year if he wants to
get a fight before that might happen in
2023 so you know i mean rankings wise
that kind of makes sense but also i mean
i'm i'm focused on winning the title
does does fighting pourier get me toward
the title i think you beat ben
or you beat islam because those guys are
the guys that are quote unquote in line
for the title charles oliveira just
just demolished those two yeah i got
finished by charles oliveira but i was
the closest guy in the last first round
seven eight nine ten fights
for two beating charles oliveira and
then if you give me the opportunity to
watch that fight make a couple changes
get the rematch fight a little bit more
smart oh you could easily see it
i beat oliver yeah that's 300 yeah i
agree for your management i think
they're going to sit down because the
voc goes all right what's sheldon want
to do do you want to do the big money
fights with diaz and connor which will
line up both those boys for him or does
he want a direct short path to the title
gets through islam guaranteeing the
title shot you know it's no you're right
and and now i'm going this way by the
way well for sure for sure but not deal
with these but not to put too much uh
you know not to put too much weight on
where i stand in the organization of
what we want to do remember i'm a i'm a
foot soldier and a pawn in some ways and
i make the right decisions for myself my
family and the company but then also
thinking about okay what's what's best
for all of us
the company as a whole michael
chandler's company as a whole you know
so i don't know if i pull that much
weight but i know i want to come in with
my work boots on as i said and do work
and then
knock it out
a little bit of chips chips in your
corner well yeah that's the thing i know
diaz was chirping right after that like
he wanted he wants the yeah
he's healthy i'm ready let's go man so
it's a it's definitely interesting you
know and you know now we just sit back
and kind of see
what's going to happen it's a good spot
to be in man i like it yeah i love it
i'm proud of you man thank you now you
don't have a fight scheduled but this
truck it's barbecue and you're on
carnivore like i am so i made sure we
got a carnivore truck for us because we
don't getting crazy out of shape like
patty pamela or anything like that
so let's stick with the carnivore diet
let me feed you and continue this talk
let's go let's do it
[Music]
trying to get my pockets bigger than a
thick boy swagger so lit it probably
make you sick boy if you looking for the
wave this is it me and griffin had to
flip it to some old school [ __ ] riding
in the whip wheels jumping on hydraulics
i've been grinding every day feeling
like a workaholic i can't even really
call it i just call it what it is do it
big like bring it and make everything
let's take a little break from chatting
with my boy
michael chandler aka the cash cow as i
call him because he has a big fight
coming up
but now a little word from our sponsor
i'm talking about better help and how
well would you take care of your car if
you have to keep the same one your
entire life that's how our brains work
man that's the engine to your body so
why don't we treat our brains this way
man it might not be cool to talk about
mental health and stuff like that but it
should be and it's getting better it's
getting a lot better man better help is
here to help you guys out
guys gals whoever you are you need help
and you're sick of talking to your
friends you need professional counseling
that's right better help is online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat only therapy sessions so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours professional therapy man
it does some wonders for people out
there including myself
and uh the food truck viewers and
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com
that's betterhelphelp.com
now let's get back to the program let's
do it boss how you doing man how you
doing man
thanks for having us brother thanks for
doing this man thanks for the invite
yeah a little kelly's barbecue i'm not
mad at it man yes sir you're talking
about two carnivore kids here we only
eat meat all right i'll do the the combo
i don't need the sides i'll just do the
ribs and the brisket combo no size
ribs and brisket would you like it for
barbecue sauce oh yeah please all right
what about for you i'll do the exact
same thing can i do barbecue sauce on
the side
ribs and brisket anything to drink uh
you have diet coke nothing diet i have
lemonade
is this kool-aid i thought i smelled
kool-aid yes that's kool-aid yes sir
i'll take some kool-aid
kool-aid since i was a kid yeah exactly
there's nothing better than kool-aid no
let's go he can't he's not gonna have
kool-aid because he's a better person i
know i'm good but not a better person
he's currently fighting so he won't have
kool-aid but i have to fight for nothing
so i will have kool-aid i'm gonna take
it off hell yeah i'll take that cooler
for the nostalgia hell yeah i got you
perfect man best truck ever two minutes
that'll come up all right thanks sir
thank you
gotta get the kool-aid man i thought i
smelled
kool-aid but now i'm on my way
stayed up every single night and hustled
every day i've been going so hard now
i'm on my way like
now i'm on my way
came in as an underdog but
[Music]
i tried my basket carnivore now i should
took um
your uh idea and not get barbecue they
really
they'd really drench this bad boy
barbecue now it does look good you know
barbecue is good when it's like a dark
color oh
yeah so it's gonna get pretty sloppy
we're both wearing white so that's so
cool that was a good idea hell yeah dude
um how long you been doing carnivore for
so i actually started experimenting with
it in my last training camp but then you
know well maybe not you because you're a
heavyweight but like you don't want to
experiment too much in training camp
right mess with your energy but i was
doing i was doing a lot of a lot of
avocado
bone marrow i was getting bone marrow
from this place down in florida and then
liver so i was doing trying to do liver
like once a week it's like keto yeah
right because you're doing high fat it's
more keto yeah i mean once i
once i because i was coming off of
eating some carbs going into training
camp once i switched my body over to
burning mainly fat then i was doing
mainly fat very little carbs whatsoever
how did you feel i felt great honestly i
don't know if it was placebo effect
sometimes too you're in the you're in a
training camp too and you're just like
okay well i don't have a choice but to
feel good today yeah so you're just like
it's gentle yeah and now you're just
doing you're trying carnivore before you
go into camp i wonder i don't know
because you know i ride my bike all the
time i hike i do just like meat and
potatoes in the weight room at zoo
culture i do like deadlifts bench
shoulders meathead stuff
so i can't really like my energy my
strength is fine but i don't know like
i'll do the tough mudders which are you
know i'll eat carbs before i do a tough
mudder yeah but i don't know if you do
carnivore and just base your fuel source
off just straight meat i don't know if
it's so carnivore
i don't know it's true
who knows who created carnivore but
whatever and actually what carnivore is
yeah exactly it's kind of like
it's kind of like fasting some people
say you hear it all on rogan's show like
hey fasting you break your fast if you
have coffee and then some people say no
you can have coffee some people say you
can have black coffee but not cream
you're like yeah
can't have cream everything's a modified
version of a certain label right so for
me i'm doing mainly meat and fats
a little bit of veggies here and there
if i take my wife out to dinner and she
orders brussels sprouts and asparagus
and stuff i'm not gonna be like sorry
babe you know so it's easier for you
obviously you know you're fighting at a
world class left when you have these
huge fights come up so it's interesting
to die but my diet gets a little dicey
i'll be super strict during the week but
then if my son's like dad i want to go
see
minions i'll take him to minions and
we're there it's one of those theaters
we can order food you know so i'll get
not you don't be the weird dad who's
always on a diet yeah my sounds like
what are you getting ready for well and
actually dude honestly
buddy well
and actually it's kind of sad shout out
to kool-aid but yeah he's got kool-aid
but honestly
my son has kind of developed that a
little bit that's all he's gonna ask you
because i and it's and it's really sad
for for a moment me and my wife are like
hey we gotta like you need to make sure
you eat an oreo with them or eat some
cheez-its
because i mean he's since he's his brain
has developed enough these last couple
years you know before when he was a year
or two he's not thinking about anything
but now he's he's old enough to notice
that daddy comes home on the weekends
but you know even on my birthday daddy
couldn't eat a birthday cake in april
because i was fighting in may so we got
a birthday cake but he could eat it but
i couldn't so then in his little mind
he's like well shoot if it's not good
for dad yeah it's not good for dad and
it's not good for me when really we
don't make it a non-safe space for the
eating but it is just like hey daddy
can't eat this right for these reasons
so we have to be really careful yeah the
other day we got it shredded he is
shredded he is shredded but but it's
more mental than it is physical you know
i don't care if he's you know what i'm
having like that association with like
sugar and junk food where it's like yeah
oh no this is horrible because then
those kids get in high school middle
school and the weird kid who yeah you
know their sweet tooth is a banana yes
you have to yes you have to be you have
to be careful with it so i find myself
the other day we got donuts and i was
like i made sure i eat it in front of
them and i ate a second washed
afterwards exactly yeah no
then i wouldn't puke oh no dad why are
you throwing up
no that's what i do but but it's kind of
funny that you bring it up yeah because
just with as an as a byproduct of my
career i have to be in a eat perfect
in eat perfect season that's your
business you know and i think it's good
for your kids i think it's good that
dad's not eating mcdonald's and fast
food 24 7 all the sugar
like i'll tell my son i'm like oh dad
don't you want to can i'm like no dude i
like to be big and strong yeah like that
it's good to do that sometimes but if
you just do that you're not going to be
big you're not going to be strong big
strong and they got a parenting tip we
talk about growing it's like well when
you eat a cheese it you might not grow
but if you eat you know broccoli or you
eat food then you're going to grow a
little bit more you know maybe that's
the wrong way to do it listen as you
know parenting you're just flying by the
seat of your pants yeah he's trying to
figure out i thought all those parents
knew what they were doing they probably
didn't know what they were doing when we
were growing up either they're just
figuring out what my pants were insane
they just figured it out my mom
said we had pizza every night cheese
pizza like a teenage mutant ninja turtle
kind of unhealthy yeah if you're an
athlete or you had stuff going on we did
pizza
spaghetti it was okay though because you
were playing so much as a kid back then
like i burned all that [ __ ] off but now
i'm eating from uh yeah it's not good
but um now you're uh added to the
chandler family yeah another baby april
19th april 19th my second son was born i
thought may 7. so i was
i left florida
went out we adopted them and then i was
in a hotel room in a hospital for a
couple days i flew back to florida my
wife flew back to tennessee my son half
flew back to tennessee he went back to
school so like how's that work like
i heard the adopt to adopt a child is
like it's not easy it's like a process
right it is and it's well it's a process
and everybody's journey and story is
different unless you're michael
challenge you just go in there i'll take
that one whoa wrap them up no the well
the funny thing is that we almost i
don't want to talk even too much about
even like hap's story because it was it
was very quick for me very very quick
but there's some people who are waiting
on a waitlist for years i know and
there's so many kids out there i have
people yeah i have people in like a
community of people that i kind of help
with adoption or i'm praying for like
hey we're looking into this whatever and
like there's people that are waiting a
year year and a half and now the process
takes a while because you got to get a
stack of paperwork this month
fbi background check uh criminal history
physical background check i had to go in
get a physical get my blood drawn do i
have any history of this that the other
thing oh wow fingerprints in
you know all the different states that
we were eligible in so jesus yes
i heard it's like people think oh i'm
just going to adopt but it's a beast now
you're
i guess my question oh this isn't too
personal oh boy why yeah why why adopt
and not have your own because you you
and your wife are i mean you guys are
well good questions
you know what i'm saying like you put
those gene pools together man
you guys are taking over the world you
want to have your own little channelers
running around
it's like with your wife's face your
body it's so funny and i've thought
about that and but ever since my wife
was like 14 15 years old she wanted to
adopt she never want to have her own no
it's not that she didn't want to have
her own she just knew she wanted to
adopt and then it's almost kind of it's
almost kind of like once you've done it
once we were like holy cow this was
so much better than we thought it
superseded so much of the expertise
just i mean i think it and i think it's
hard for somebody to understand because
people i see the comments online or this
whatever people say well there's no way
that you could love an adopted child as
much as you would love your own genes
and i don't know until
yeah until you have felt that and you
felt the love of a child and you felt
the love that you've had for a child
whether he i mean he he's an
african-american with dark skin and like
looks different
we don't exactly but that's what i'm
saying we don't look alike so i don't
need i but i never needed my son to be
you know brown eyes and brown hair and
walk around like me to love him i mean
it's very it's a very shy it's a very
shallow way to look at a human life and
a child and i'm like
i fell in love with my son happ in
october of 2017 and
since then we were like we knew we were
going to do it again
and then it's just you just
you're just trying to figure out
what you want and for honestly for us
from that moment we never thought about
having our own children as much as we
thought about adopting again so then
that's when you know
doors are opened or certain doors close
or you know just
and that's honestly been our our journey
and we've enjoyed it so much
more power to you i couldn't do it like
listen there's nothing i love more on
this freaking planet than my six and
two-year-old is the best in the world
but if that kid wasn't my flesh and
blood the verbal and physical abuse i
take from this child like i'll get home
today dude you talk [ __ ] to me throw
stuff at me that wasn't my kid i'm like
get out no dude i guarantee it and it's
funny because you never know because i
don't know what it's like to have a
biological child you know so i don't
know what i would feel yeah i mean same
with adopting like it's you know having
a kid is scary dude it's like your
anxiety is through the roof all times
we go the movie theaters just the
culture we live in i'm thinking like
someone comes in here with a gun we
always sit in the back my dad's like my
son's always like dad why can't we sit
in the front i'm like i don't like the
front so i'm i can't even enjoy the
movie i'm looking around at exits and
[ __ ] like a psychopath bro yeah that's
the cultural land that's the messed up
world we live in there yeah yeah it's
not good yeah
but the funny thing is i
i think about all that same stuff same
struggles
that someone with a biological child
goes through same struggles as
same highs same lows same
everything let me ask you this is it
like
is it like that movie me myself and
irene with jim carrey and the three
black kids do they know like they
they're you're not their actual father
like are they at the age well my son
does yes and that was
that was one part of our journey that we
always wanted to do is we have open
adoptions where we
have contact with birth mothers birth
fathers like
we
our son happ knows he's adopted we pray
for his birth mom every night we talk
about his birth mom often we talk about
the word adoption we want to make we
want to make the word
adoption a a positive uplift you take
the power of negativity for sure you
know and even and even other you know
other kids will come up and say well why
doesn't he have the same color skin as
you and you just explain to them god
makes families in a lot of different
ways some some
god makes some families through a mommy
and a daddy and he makes some families
through adoption he makes something mind
your business
stupid clearly
that's your parents
fourth grade educate yourself figure it
out he's like i'm three certain
stupid questions um no questions a dumb
question yeah except for that except for
that one that was [ __ ] stupid
all right let's take a little break from
chatting with my boy meg michael
chandler aka the cash cow as i call him
because he has a big fight coming up
but now a little word from our sponsor
i'm talking about better help and how
well would you take care of your car if
you have to keep the same one your
entire life that's how our brains work
man that's the engine to your body so
why don't we treat our brains this way
man
it might not be cool to talk about
mental health and stuff like that but it
should be and it's getting better it's
getting a lot better man better help is
here to help you guys out
guys gals whoever you are you need help
and you're sick of talking to your
friends you need professional counseling
that's right better help is online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat only therapy sessions so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours professional therapy man
it does some wonders for people out
there including myself
and uh the food truck viewers and
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com
that's betterhelphelp.com
now let's get back to the program yeah
so
and they're are they from africa are
they from they're from north they're
from united states
they're just following hard times or
they just don't have the means to
support a child it's always it's always
different i mean and it's i mean i think
there's just a
there's such a bigger plan at work
happening you know
well when it comes to
do you think about just the the
specific birth mom or even the scenario
or do you think about
i truly believe that i was put on this
earth to be hap's dad to me ace's dad
love it when i was born great freaking
36 years ago yeah
so
i think it's just you're
you're being led by it all obviously i
mean we have prayed for hap since me and
bri got together when i first decided we
were going to adopt because i didn't
really choose it she said hey this is
what i've always wanted to do how do you
feel about it
took me a while to yeah of course and i
was like i'm in yeah um
after a little while and then you know
we've been praying for him since
2000
whatever it was 12 when we got together
13 and then now ace and the cool the
cool thing about ace our second son was
great as we talked about
you know your six-year-old is is isn't
just a kid anymore he's he's a big
brother and that's a huge responsibility
and i think
not putting the pressure of the
responsibility but putting the the
ownness and the accountability and the
pride of being a big brother you don't
want to be like hey now you know half
our attention is going to this little
dude so get ready dude
we didn't do that when uh boston was
born we brought tiger in i meant
your brother came to the world dude like
this this is your this is your little
brother man so you know this is on you
take care of them like here's your
brother like we made it like ownership
for him so he felt so much pride and
responsibility and then he's like the
best big brother ever yeah it's it's so
cool and it's really cool to see that
relationship and in the adoption process
obviously there wasn't the the nine
months of hey mommy is is pregnant yeah
you know we do just showed up yeah we
you know because you want to keep it you
want to protect him by keeping it
completely secret until it's 100 yeah
he's your baby brother
so seeing that and now seeing the last
couple of months or god bless you it's
been
so much better with two oh so much
better yeah i heard three's easier well
yeah four is even easier
the other day my wife was talking about
number three so we're like well i'll do
i want nine of them there's nothing
better also god your kids i mean granted
they've brought so much value to your
life but those little dudes won the
lottery michael chandler's your dad you
know what i'm saying these kids won the
goddamn lottery dude i don't know man
yeah that's what people say like
i think that's one of the biggest
things that i really enjoy people saying
like hey you know that's so cool that
what you did
for the world for these kids whatever
take away all your accolades being a
fighter you're good that's why when i
say when the lottery like you're a good
person your wife is a good person you
know and you do things the right way and
you have values and we need more people
like you so even though it's not your
flesh and blood those they are then
they're going to be you're going to be
you cannot come you're going to be great
no they are
the same values that you were brought up
and we need more michael challenges in
this world you know what i'm saying so
that's why those kids won the lottery
because you know you have money or
success it's because you're their dad
and you know they have this great mom
who have a foundation they're going to
take care of them yeah yeah i know it's
and it's it's really cool i mean it's
and i just see it as these dudes have
blessed me so so much man it changed
your life same whether it's biological
children adopted children i mean
children of any
sort or however any means that you that
you create the family it's just such an
amazing amazing thing and most important
thing you ever do also the best like you
know same with you like we've done some
cool [ __ ] i've been yeah i've been some
big ufc fights i've been big college
football
games you know i've i've performed at
huge you know theaters and big you know
economy store laugh factory improv
nothing has compared to being a dad you
know what i'm saying it's a great title
blows all that away and it's the
greatest title that you will ever ever
attain and acquire because as men we're
wired to go attain acquire build create
but the most important title that we'll
ever have is dad you know and it's and
it's and it's something that gets
glossed over sometimes because we have
so much stuff going on or it's hey
they'll be fine and it and to a certain
extent yeah you have to be self you have
to be selfish at times in order to be
selfless you know i mean even me man
leaving my family for eight to ten weeks
at a time oh when i go on twitter i came
on
it's like i'm gone for three days it's a
nightmare yeah i hate it but without
without you doing that and feeding your
soul and creating your passion you're
actually
you're a shell of the man that you were
created to be therefore you can't be a
good fighter and i'll say this to one
like once you have like now you have two
kids
it creates some
just like
you go to a different level as a man as
a dad as especially as a fighter as a
comic or you know a business owner you
just have this like fire inside you now
because now you gotta take care of
another human being where it's just like
you don't even notice it but it's like
this dad power activates in you yeah
that's why i feel sorry for the next day
yeah yeah papa bear power is
you know my last fight happ was there
which was
awesome that i won but dude it was it
was the most pressure probably i've ever
felt in my entire life not the i mean
there was other stuff going on i had
lost two in a row at that point yeah you
know fight of the years and title fights
whatever but you still still you still
lost your last two go to where you want
to go you can't lose to tony ferguson
and tell yourself and tell anybody that
you're you know vying for the title
that's good after that and then my son
was there you know and it was it was a
lot of a lot of pressure i didn't didn't
lead on like it was but it was a lot of
pressure my god did it work out it
worked out well now not only is it
working out but like i said you're the
cash cow for the the ufc and then you
know i do the shop show my boys brought
up they go
chandler was on mass singer
i'm like jesus christ
math singer how'd that come about dude
actually my nanny my nanny was like
hey michael i i don't ever want to you
know put your name out there whatever
like i'm part of this group and they
were looking nashville was doing la or
they were doing live shows um last thing
you're live right mastering your life so
it was a live show of the mass singer
um
and they said hey do you know any you
know local celebrities that might want
to be a part of this and she's like i
didn't throw your name in there and i
told her i was like we're this is our
first fight we're in a fight i can't
believe you didn't throw my name out
there she's like i didn't know that you
know i'm like i was like call him or
text him right now and then three hours
later they were like hey you know do you
want to be on it it's july whatever it
was i'm like yeah absolutely and they're
like okay i'm like do i need to do an
audition or whatever like no no you got
the part if you want to do it i'm like
okay and then how did you pick the song
um it was between like four or five
there was there was like garth brooks
and there was old town road i knew i
didn't want to do a dude because my
voice is so bad i didn't i didn't want
to like butcher a good song yeah you
know butchered garth brooks like his
royalties yeah yeah and
they would hang you in yeah so i did so
i did uh hit me baby one more time by
freaking britney
i'm not mad at the vocals either those
are so bad dude man i don't maybe it was
our bad speakers i hope so i was like
you can kind of sing no
well there was auto i had it in my ears
and i was like dang dude this is so bad
it almost like messed up my you know
dancing and i was wearing a boom box
only like this much of my hands were
sticking out so i had to like lift it up
to like shake my butt a little bit and
like
i was just like you glad you did it
though oh yeah your wife go with you
yeah my wife was there yeah she's like
this is ridiculous yeah she's she of
course she's my you know one of my worst
critics when it comes to like that funny
stuff she's like your voice was so bad
i'm like babe come on it wasn't that bad
you know she's like no it was pretty bad
it was pretty bad
was there oh
god yeah will i love jar over there so
he actually started taking a video and
he's like oh hell no like as soon as he
heard like the vocals for the first time
and uh they said they were going to auto
tune it better you know or maybe that
was the best they could do but it was to
me it was pretty bad i thought it was
pretty good oh thank you don't hate on
you man you'd have will and uh taylor do
it oh for sure a tandem for sure i
actually you know i was i was going to
put their name in the hat for the next
one but i don't know right they're great
i don't know what's got the bustling the
boys well before we get you out of here
we always do uh i always give every
guest a shoe because all right biggest
sneakerhead you know my man yes you are
and you came in i said oh you got the
harachi's on you said i have no idea
what i didn't know
and i said that's how i know you're a
dad because you go for comfort uh-huh
you came in there with crocs i just like
we're not shooting i saw your video the
croc thing the other day dude during the
crocs that's bad drive me nuts anyways
it'd be hilarious if i gave you crops no
yeah these are not crocs these are the
ultimate statue they are the most
hypebeast statue of all time okay you're
a new dad and you like comfort mm-hmm
but you're also the the cash cow of the
ufc now your next your next ufc fight is
gonna be a big boy
so you need some big boy dad shoe
superstar shoes well
these are the easy dad shoes dude soak
those in those are from my friends at
suplex and philly oh bro and they
usually i go what are you guys thinking
and i told him i said dude i need the
original yeezy dad shoes these are dudes
easy boost 700's they're the most
comfortable shoe i own are they really i
wear them dude i'm on my line in them
i'll look at my ficuses in them i'll do
dad kisses do i do dad daddy's [ __ ] in
these daddy stuff you get extra daddy
yeah they're comfortable extra daddy in
these bad boys and they're also dope
yeah they can wear them with jeans you
wear them out you wear dinner tonight
the thing you got tonight you do all
that i'm aware these are dinner tonight
with that for you my man's ultimate dad
appreciate you bro the ufc cash cow
michael chandler
[Music]
[Music]
super